soit au jour soit on meurt
on a eu la chance de sortir vivant de
ses escape room je veux être sûr que
ceux qui ont tué quatre personnes devant
moi auront à répondre de leurs actes ils
planquent souvenait de tout le monde
ammann à table il faut qu'on les arrête
je viens
je suis consciente de ce que je te
demande je te remercie m'accompagner
dans tout ça
et qu'est ce que c'est que ce banc des
dragons à vis des couplets
attendait juste une blague
vous avez déjà participé à dieu alors
c'est quoi ça le tournoi des champions
on connaît tous la règle du jeu on
résout les énigmes non mais toutes les
mauvaises publicités doivent être
étendus sur celle là radio self il
manque un e on descend les poignets qui
correspondent aux lettres manquantes
jeu du pendu et mais
on a pris un peu de temps
la wpc
[Musique]
c'est bien plus grand plat dernière fois
on va pas rester là les bras croisés
nous a survécu pour une raison bien
précise je suis insensible à la douleur
physique je te laisse imaginer le genre
dénis qui nous réserve et
prenez une photo fait durer leur teint
terne audi on dirait le phare de la
capitale
j'en ai marre du filet
on peut les battre à leur propre jeu
qu'est ce qui dit qu'il fallait sortir
encore une fois
c'est pas mal
faire tuer
n'est pas
ni semaine
a réussi un arrêt c
je comprends pas on est toujours dans le
jeu